Mới 2 mì từ tháng bài, Malaysia với VJ Chủ Tíc Lên phía N' Asian đã chủ động của ý thông điểm tới lãnh đạo Hai Nước.
Ông đã đối thoại với lãnh đạo Thái Lan và Cápu Chia khẳng định hoa bình là lối thoát dưới nhất.
Thủ tưởng Malaysia Anwar ebrah him sau đó sức nhận Thái Lan và Cápu Chia nếu đã thể hiện thiện chỉ đồ với địa xuân này,
và hay bên sẵn sàng xem xét khả năng lửa rau trang.
Bình hoài khu vực, tổng tức kiên liên thập quốc Antonio của Terran của Kio Hỏi Nước kiểm chế và giải kết mất đồng, thông qua đối thoại trên tình thành lãnh dựa vấn nghĩ.
Chức đó chính phủ hàng gia, các mùi Chia đã tổ chức học báo cũng cấp thông tin cập nhận vì tình gí rửa xuân đó quân sự trên truyền miên giới với Thái Lan.
Thè dưới chức căn bù Chia nức nếm ông muốn hoa bình và giải phát quân sự là lửa trọn cuối cùng.
Cầm buồn chiều cũng nhấn mạnh sẽ không lui bước trong việc mẹ đơn kiểu nạn,
linh toàn công li của T-I-C-A, được mỗi mùi số khu vực chính chấp.
Trong khi đó, quyền thử tưởng Thái Lan, phương tham về thái chá trại, hẳng định các khảnh động xung đồ dưới 2 bên phải chấm rất,
thì mơ có thể tiến thành đam phán nhằm hạn nghiệt cân thẳng.